[Music]
give the agent the go ahead miss james
okay sam we've trained for the situation
and you know what to do
missions ago been breached
[Music]
a talking ape i prefer chimp
[Music]
this is the earliest known photo of
daniel hall
he's attempting to build some sort of
new weapon he must be stopped
have an idea we going to take over oh
attacking is that part of the plan i
didn't know that
is attacking part of the plan to take
over the world clearly you're new to
this whole evil thing
when humanity faces its greatest threat
it's imperative we have that data
a careful partner one hero
sam that's disgusting
you'll swing into action
maintaining an appropriate level of
physical training is important
please this is a serious mission
yes don't leave me hanging i should be
running this operation
me thank you you're one mysterious
monkey don't hate the player hate the
game
my dad right madeleine keynes sophia omg
skip schweink do that where you going
never mind i don't care take this back
to the lab
saving the world is all
monkey business
who was that funky monkey c.i.a
[Music]
bye